The forest model performed
quite well with the 60% of
employees that responded to the survey.
Yet just like in all the other models
presented in this classification
section, we should test the model
out with a validation sample to
determine how well our forest model
actually performs on independent data.
So what we're going to do is just
continue on with the same workflow that
we have already built out with the input
data tool, the samples of our data set,
the decision tree model, or rather the
forest model, and now we need to bring
in a model comparison tool to validate
our model with a validation data set.
Again we take the model object
into the end or model site and
the validation data set into the D or
data site.
We will now bring in our browse tool
after the R over our output and
kick off this work flow.
Now with this tool we can see that the
model accuracy of the validation sample
is that 85%.
This is again quite lower than
the estimation sample that was
predicted before,
which was much much higher.
So, just like the decision tree model,
both of our results fell
from predicting the estimation sample
down to the validation sample.
I think I remember that these
results are a little bit higher than
the decision tree, but we're going to
need to compare them side by side to
determine which one is actually
better for prediction.
Also, we may have another model up our
sleeves that we can test out to see
maybe this model might perform better
than both of these other ones so far.